welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm very excited to
be joined by
dan dan zhu who is the founder and ceo
of dan dan global and dg recruit
dan dan started her recruitment career
in 2011 where she rapidly progressed
from trainee to principal within two
years
and by the time dan dan left in 2016
she founded um their executive search
practice for the agency that she worked
for and
for the last five years she's been
supporting hundreds of executives with
her career coaching business
dan dan global and for the last three
years
she's been connecting top billers with
top recruitment firms across the us
with dg recruit dan dan welcome to the
podcast
thank you so much for having me hisham
so where we always start and the first
question i have for you
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think make up
a highly successful recruitment
consultant
absolutely this is a question obviously
every recruitment company
will tell us over and over again and
we've seen certain
things not only through my personal
practice but through my own experience
working in an environment to see what
works and what does it
and it fundamentally comes down to the
core drive
to be financially well-off i think this
is still a very deep-seated
need to sustain one's career in such a
challenging job
right there's so many ways that you can
make money outside of recruitment
the only reason why you would use
recruitment as a vehicle for wealth
is if you truly have the commercial
acumen to understand how this industry
works
so i think it's got to be someone who's
business savvy who
has probably seen the world a little bit
who understand
you know what a typical job looks like
and how recruitment is a completely
different and unique
beast of a job so it's just someone who
kind of understands
and appreciates the opportunity that
this business provides
and is willing to you know sacrifice for
the first
one to two years of their career to
truly learn the business be a student
gather all the information and really
push oneself
to be a sales leader so the people that
really succeed are the ones that
understand this is commercial
business driven by revenue generation
and that you have to push yourself to
appreciate and understand how to
convert a thought into money right a
thought of i want to play
somebody i want to get jobs to actually
doing it and having the guts and the
courage to do so
also along with that you need the work
ethic to be able to
sustainably create your business through
time
which requires a lot of dedication and
man hours it's a very
you know manual job it's not just
something that falls into your lap
you know you have to work hard towards
it i mean all of these different factors
combined
in addition to just basic ability to
speak
well and to write well these are all
crucial skill sets that today's
recruitment consultant
has been able to do and improve upon
do do you think that most
high-performing recruiters that you know
work with
are their main motivator and driver is
money
i would say probably nine times out of
ten absolutely
okay i find that interesting the reason
why
i want to dig into that is because i've
i speak to so many
top performing recruiters who hit the
goal that they're after
that become financially free or whatever
and and feel empty
feel they've they don't know they don't
know why they're doing it anymore
they're unmotivated so
what i keep hearing and i don't know if
this may be a nuance to the american
market but what i keep hearing is that
the best recruiters that build a
successful career sustainably
are really fine-tuned into their purpose
and that typically has got to be bigger
than
a material object or a sort of a certain
number in their bank account what do you
think about that
oh i don't really know about other
people's feelings towards that it's just
when we see people who have reached a
certain level of success
it's usually because they had a serious
y
right and the y is deeper than dollars
and cents
right it's really the why driving
someone to aspire to have
a successful life which usually entails
some sort of financial success
right like you can't in our world
success is determined by
your ability to produce and your ability
to share
in the profit of your production
right in the reward so it's very rare to
come across someone who does it
simply for joy or for fulfillment
because
in this career it's kind of like a
thankless job it you know candidates
sometimes will will not be the nicest
two clients certainly
will not be the nicest to you we do it
for the money
i mean i i i've consistently done this
job since i was 23
and i still do it for the money i still
do it for the money it's fantastic i
love it
i love financial reward i love success i
love feeling
amazing that i can create something from
nothing
and challenge myself you know almost
like a mindset
can i build another 500 can i build
another million can i do this can i do
that every step
is a challenge with financial wins at
the end so
it's very hard for me to conceive why
people would sustain and do this tough
job
it's a very tough job to call clients to
ask them for certain things to call
candidates
and put their feet to the fire be really
harsh
on people and be real tough and you're
controlling as many factors as you can
i don't really understand why people
would do that for simple intellectual
curiosity
you know i don't see why that would be
the case right again
i think it comes from a deceit in need
of ego gratification
in terms of a certain level of
achievement and a certain level of
living life standard right that's why
you get into this business
again you use it for a vehicle for what
it is to wealth
and you have fun along the way you find
the joy in it you enjoy
the challenge that comes with making
more and more buildings every year maybe
building your own agency maybe building
new markets
but the fundamental reason of why we get
into this business still
is financial reward so again i i don't
really know
uh but a lot of the people that we talk
to who exit the business
don't care that much about financial
reward and that's why they exit
because they're like it's not worth the
trouble it's not worth
the suffering they don't ultimately see
you know and care about this
amazing sort of financial opportunity to
them it's like
i know it's there i understand the
commercial aspect
but i don't care i have x amount and
that's good enough for me
and for me it's like oh that's there's
no such thing as that x
amount being like the target and that
being over for me it's always going to
be evolving
more and more growing my net worth it's
always going to be growing it and not
just growing it dollar by dollar growing
it by
you know severe chunks of money right so
you need a acceleration
in terms of a wealth building vehicle
and for me it's
it's recruitment as a core that drives
all my other
investment behavior right so i think
again
i don't really know you know of course
some people get bored they get
demotivated in their own way in their
own and sometimes
attributed to their work environment the
people they're surrounding themselves
with
um the maybe loneliness sometimes of
being uh
potentially a solopreneur um whatever
comes with that
um but for me it's always every time i
feel demotivated
i look to my financial drive and i look
to the goals that i have financially
and that always gives me hope that
always gives me a dream to aspire to
otherwise i could just do some other job
that's easier
yeah and i i think that what thank you
for sharing that i think what
what why i wanted you to sort of go a
bit further on that is because is where
you started that which is the sort of
deep
rooted why um and i think do you think
then i know
there's things that i want to go into
but just just on there so
if if if you if you believe that do you
think that that
that being really anchored to the
financial reward do you think that
encourages
good practice in recruitment
i think it's about who how you look at
business
and how you want to grow your business
there are a lot of people out there
that are shady and that like to take
shortcuts i've never been somebody who's
done that
um in fact very early on in recruitment
i realized that earning people's trust
and
living off of their goodwill is how is
the easiest way to build a recruitment
practice
right you do might by your people in
your network
they will sell for you they'll drive
half of your
business you know your word of mouth the
reputation precedes you
so for me it's not because i'm
altruistic or human or like
morally supreme it's just simply
smart business to treat people well and
to give them
good service and to tell them to spread
the word for you
so for anyone who takes shortcuts and i
see people do that in my network
certainly back to rack it's a messy
business and i've talked to a lot of my
competitors
and i've seen i've talked to a lot of
candidates who complain about the other
rack tracks
and that's just never something i've
ever done because
i've built a successful practice from
age 23
over and over again by being good to
people being likable
leveraging my likability having people
sell for me
and really being on my side and
therefore you expand faster
your results are exponential because
people like you and that's like a hidden
accelerator right your reputation
precedes you so
again i mean to me it's just like
playing simple
regular common sense to provide a strong
offering
an above average offering for your
customers
so that everybody kind of knows you're
the best and then for that you can also
charge higher rates
right so this is just like basic
business common sense for me
to do good work and to be a good person
to make the money you want to make i
don't want to commit crimes to make
money
i want to commit like regular things
that i can sleep at night like i can
sleep at night every single night
because i don't do anything shady right
like everything i do is above board
right recruiting for creepers i even
talk to clients that try to do me dirty
obviously they're no longer clients and
i'm just like i don't understand how you
sleep at night
i really don't i don't just to save a
couple dollars
it's sad yeah like i love that like you
know
i believe in positive greed greed can be
a very powerful positive motivator
yeah love that so dan dan how would you
describe
your first year in recruitment
my first year recruitment was really fun
i was in a really cool environment where
i was allowed
to be myself and i think i just love
this career from day one
because you can leverage again your
personality to its
very fullest extent and i think that's
the biggest difference i
felt about recruitment as a career
versus every other
job right in the past i've worked in
banks i've worked at
you know medical device companies i was
interning many months and i was like
these jobs are so
boring right you're just stuck in a silo
you
just have to do a certain like x task
but for recruiting it's like
literally living and breathing this new
way of life
i'm like how do i generate money out of
literally nothing
right we had no clients we had no
candidate network
it's like how do you make money out of
literally nothing
except your own until you make energy
right so my first year was like
accelerated learning where i mean my
first two
three months i would constantly work
weekends
i would work till nine pm most weekdays
and every day my life was just work and
then like gearing up for
work and working so i was really
immersed in the career when i first
started because
i had to develop and invest a lot of
time
in learning what i had to do and putting
the time into the hours
needed to have the conversations i need
to have so that i could accelerate
the process of mastering the jargon that
you need to learn
when you're just starting to recruit
because you have to
speak differently right as a 23 year old
selling to 55 year olds
you can't just communicate the way you
want to communicate with your friends
or with your teachers you know it's a
totally different business
jargon to sound adult like
and to earn their trust so my first few
months and the first
year was really just mastering the new
language
and earning people's respect and trust
and that's how you
get business done at the end of the day
mm-hmm and what what what
was it what well did you recruit in just
for context
i worked in the pharmaceutical space so
my job was to sell to pharmaceutical
companies including biotechs
yeah awesome because
awesome because what i wanted to ask you
about that uh early period right and i'm
sure you
like one of the reasons why i started
this podcast was because
when i got into recruitment i got sold
the recruitment dream
right which was let you win six figures
in your first year
and you'll do all these things but i
didn't get told around what you're
talking about
the steep learning curve the amount of
rejection you have to go through the
amount of time you have to pull yourself
up off the floor all these things right
so um what always find what i find
interesting i'm seeing on your linkedin
you put like literally within sort of
two years if i'm correct you built
something from scratch
right as you as you shared where you you
managed to build
build 1.5 million right in in two years
is that right in dollars yeah
oh in three years in three years three
years right okay yeah in three years
yeah so so so that that's pretty
significant
right um in in terms from a stand start
and i know there'll be loads of
different factors into that
but i guess if we were to sort of work
that down to one to three things you've
spoken about work ethic
get that not everyone's going to be
prepared to do what you do i've heard
you talk on
obviously other podcasts where you've
you've got um
you come from an asian family and work
ethic is huge right and you have a chip
on your shoulder
you have things to prove so so i get
that but you
i like the way that you're talking about
that you really focused on learning
and building trust so i guess you speak
to people the time that enter the
industry
that don't have that success what what
do you think
the other two three things that you
really doubled down on that helped you
achieve that
um i think one is just again unless
oh i can't hear you maybe maybe take the
there was a fault take the airpods out
oh that's fine yeah perfect
excited about that um yeah in addition
to the work ethic and when i talk work
ethic i mean
really like being clever about how you
utilize your time work
so a lot of people at work are just not
focused
and they don't really commit themselves
to this career
and kind of going back to my earlier
point when i got into the business i
realized the financial
opportunity in recruitment is unlike any
other business model compared to real
estate sales compared to financial
wealth sales compared to a lot of other
careers
so i made a commitment day one coming
into the business
that this was gonna be my thing and that
i was gonna amount to somebody i was
gonna be
top biller i'm gonna be like on the top
of the leaderboard like that was a
decision i made when i entered the
business
and my mentality was i simply will not
fail at this
not only will i not fail at this i will
be one of the best people they ever
hire and i will set the example so
that was like ego driving me so
every time i talk to a client or a
candidate it would it would be like
everything
meant survival right it was like it
wasn't just like oh maybe see
if you can grab a you know a lead
maybe see maybe it was not there was no
mate it was just
i had to keep going tenaciously until i
got every single drop of information
i could possibly purchase right so it's
like this
cutthroat energy of like i will not let
the prospects go
until i get what i need so i guess it's
a bit of ego it's a bit of
tenacity it's a bit of shamelessness
it's just like i don't care
if you don't want to take my call i'm
going to do whatever i need to do
to learn how to keep you on the phone
because right away can't
people will be like oh i'm too busy you
can't talk to you i'd be like no problem
i know you're super busy let's keep
talking i have to continue going
it's just like the shamelessness of
being like you're on my time
i'm not on your time you're on my time
because deep down aside i knew i was
gonna change their life
i knew that i was the best and i knew
that i had the biggest network
so they're missing out when they don't
talk to me i'm not missing out because
i'm gonna make money
any which way they're missing out
because they don't know it
but they need me they understand the
power
that a top recruiter can can do for you
to change your life
right i've changed so many people's
lives they just don't know it yet so
that's the mission really driving my
behavior
um when i'm talking to people so it's
this tenacity the shamelessness
is one one aspect in addition to
work ethic right work ethic on weekends
i drive
an hour and a half on my weekends to
meet candidates
because my thought was i'm not going to
spend my monday to friday when i can
call clients
to go any candidates i'm going to meet
candidates on saturdays and sundays
i'm going to take them out to lunch for
coffee i do three or four meetings at a
day
i drive around you know it's just work
was my priority
so i guess the next two things are the
tenacity the shamelessness
and also the focus and dedication to
making this
work making this successful having the
mindset that this is my
exit plan this is my fast track to
retirement
it's not a joke right it's this serious
dedication to the craft
of making this the vehicle the chosen
vehicle
of which i'm going to leverage to power
up all of my financial goals
um yes so you're talking about and i
think
i think you i think it takes a while for
a lot of recruiters to get
to really believe that what you're
talking about that sort of real
inner belief that if if you're speaking
to me then i am the best person you
should be speaking to right
and and so i love that you really held
yourself to
really extreme high standards from from
day one and and
that's what you held yourself account to
um so i guess you mentioned focus and i
think this is really interesting
right and and i really agree on this and
one of the most popular questions that i
get
from recruiters is recruiters want to
know
what did a in in uk terms 150k
um pound biller what did their day look
like
compared to a free 400k a biller right
like so when you say focus where do
people get it wrong
with with focus like where where are
recruiters going wrong
when you feel like they're not focusing
enough
i think that the problem is sometimes a
two-fold right
one is external and so let's talk about
external
maybe you're set up in the wrong market
maybe your box has you selling to too
many different things
maybe your boss you're so we talked to a
lot of recruiters that start off
not being in control of their job racks
right so they're working someone else's
jobs
and that's really tough because if you
can't control the client side
you need to enhance it if you can't
control the client side and you're just
filling jobs
it's really hard to control the quality
and the dedication
and the hotness of those wrecks than
just getting your own racks that are
deeply committed that you can interview
the client yourself
and then conversely you can sell better
because you know
what the client is you know who they are
how they feel you've had these
conversations
you've built up a relationship and you
can sell it to the candidate community
better
right so i think one is the structure of
the company
and what they have you doing right so
when i first started it was a very
targeted
market that they assigned me it was just
out of thin air here you go i want you
to do regulatory writers
so regulatory writers is a very slim
niche vertical
similar to like biostatisticians
clinical operations right there's just
like different
verticals and i think the way i was
trained was doing
the vertical market specialism which is
very popular
in london i think it's absolutely the
right way to go about it which is become
an
absolute expert in one type of vertical
all the way from
vp to director to the top of the
vertical all the way down to junior
person in that vertical
because the goal is you're just gonna
shop and mosey around
that whole entire ladder right so i love
that i think it's the best way to go
about building a recruitment firm
relatively quickly because then you can
really become the market expert as
opposed to
a generalist recruiter who just kind of
does everything so this is what i mean
by external
when you're junior you don't know any
better so your boss is like hey i want
you to recruit a regulatory writer i
want you to also recruit the
biostatistician and i also want you to
recruit
the clinical trial associate that is
impossible
right those are three vastly different
networks there's zero
economies of scale between those
networks so i was just lucky that i
started off
in the right kind of setup where i was
just assigned
one specific vertical now it was up to
me
to then develop my vertical and this is
how i kind of did it differently which
was
i didn't really listen to my bosses at
that point it was just like okay
you're given this terror this market do
what you will with it so i just went
crazy
i just went to boston went to philly
went to jersey went to
i market mapped out every single
possible hiring person
in the market and that's why i stayed
late all those days
was adding all of them into the system
right so there's a certain amount of
like focus in
terms of time and energy that you choose
to live your life
so i was 23 years old single in new york
living on a 35k
base which isn't a lot of money after
taxes that leaves me
very little i had to pay for student
loans car loans
i was just like i need to make money i
don't have the luxury
of going to work nine to five hang out
my friends
after work and on weekends to i don't
have that luxury
i need to make money right so in my
situation
i had to focus all the living time that
i had
on work i didn't have extra time to
focus on my hobbies
or focus on hanging out with people
right year one was crucial i needed to
focus on the job
and focus on building my market and
socializing
with the network that was gonna make me
money right so i think it's again
twofold you need to be in the right
situation from a corporate setting
in terms of what they have you working
on and then also number two
taking that opportunity into your own
hands and being opportunistic
about all the commercial uh billing
opportunities that come your way
sometimes it might fall out of your
typical niche right so
like sometimes i do some other searches
if i have the time
but you need to have a core focus and
dedicate your time
to becoming an expert at your job
what what does your what does your
typical day plan
consist of today my typical day plan
today
it's just typical recruitment day same
old same old my job actually has
devolved
into being very much what it was day one
which is calling
messaging head hunting like referral
networking golden looping
it's just conversations messages a lot
of messages because now i recruit
recruiters
unlike what i used to do before which
was headhunt people
to move companies from you know here
you're going to make 100 where you
currently are great
i'm head hunting you today i'm going to
sell you a job that's going to pay you
40
000 more do you want to talk that was my
old pitch
today that's not pitch anymore because
i'm recruiting recruiters
and recruiters are paid on commission
they're not paid on base
increases so i can't call up a recruiter
at a top recruiting firm and say hey you
made 200 next last year i need 50 000
come and talk to me so that's not my
typical approach now
now i just do a lot of messaging a lot
of golden looping
because it's really about timing people
and catching people on the right day
that they actually want to discuss a
move because
recruitment market is just a different
set of goals a different set of
compensation factors so this this pitch
is no longer the same
a lot of the market dynamics are also a
little bit different
so my my big ass today my big like task
is to do a ton of messaging it's very
manual very manual i write every single
message i reach out to every
person i do proper market mapping i
literally message everyone
and in the hopes that they would do
themselves a favor
and not be naive enough to not connect
with me
unlike you know what i was like back in
the day like completely
like you know you when you say golden
light like i hope you catch people
golden looping what do you mean by that
so golden loop is your core work of
people who know you
and already you've been in contact in
some way
so a golden loop starts at the top with
placed candidates
so anybody you placed they obviously
know you and they have experienced
positively with you
so you should be hitting those people up
and asking them for referrals time to
time
as often as once every month and you
should be staying in touch with
the next layer which is anyone who has
interviewed for you so anyone who has
gone out there and interviewed you need
to be hitting them up once a month too
just ask for referrals to stay in touch
and then the third tier is anyone that
you've spoken with or met in person
right then you kind of talked it so the
goal is every single month
you should be talking to the same group
of people all the time and constantly
adding new people to your loop
that is the ideal scenario yeah i really
like that
so let's go into i i'm really excited to
dig into
sort of dan dan's perspective of of the
us recruitment
market right so how would you just so
like just to give you some context so
before covid but i feel like this is
really starting to ramp up again now so
before covid i would say
most uk-based progressive recruitment
businesses
that wanted to grow had on their
business plan
us right and some of those businesses
have continued those and some of them
may have waited whatever but that
definitely was
always in a typical conversation with a
recruitment entrepreneur right
so i'm sure there's been plenty of bumps
across the road right in the last 12
months but like today
like how would you describe the us
recruitment market for
agency recruitment it's as good as ever
in fact it's it's consistently a market
that is under utilized in terms of
there's just not enough people
to satisfy the market demand there's not
enough capable people who can
actually do the job in most u.s
recruitment markets and i'm sure
nationally and internationally
um these candidate markets are very
tight so
the ability of somebody off the street
to come in
insert themselves in a relatively
insular network
where people are paranoid and don't like
recruiters and have been burned by many
bad recruiters
that skill is still very hard to execute
even on just the candidate side right so
both sides of the job are hard
like even penetrating candidate markets
so what you hear a lot in the
recruitment market in
in america is oh i don't i just can't
find these candidates
i just can't find candidates and i'm
just like well that is really sad
because that's literally your only job
like if you can't do that you cannot do
this job
like that's just unfortunate because
it's like saying i'm a lawyer and i
don't know how to law
right like it's just this is your job
right
this if you don't figure it out you're
out of a job
that's it it's over so the problem today
is you just have a lot of people
that either lack the work ethic
organization
ability to call in consistently right
some of these candidates you have to
call them 10 times a day
and i hear people saying oh i call them
once a day or i call them once a week
good luck well you are really playing
the odds there that that one day that
you call them on monday they're gonna
pick up at that exact moment in time
right so i think i think the answer is
this is a phenomenal
career that just in general very few
people
either know about so that's the thing in
america not a lot of people
know that this career even exists
they've heard about hr they've heard
about corporate recruiting
they don't know what a headhunter is i
didn't know
and i went to a business school a
relatively good one so
we didn't know anything unless your
family was rich
and your parents were head hunted you
don't know what a
headhunter is in america so some middle
class kid like me
i don't know about headhunters my
parents work in a restaurant
nobody's head hunting them for anything
so i don't know
that headhunting is a thing right so
same and that's college educated right
so
the american population has no idea
that this career even exists so because
of that
there's just not a lot of people
entering the field
and those who do a lot of them are not
cut out for it and the
vast majority leave it's a stopover it's
a stop gap right so what happens is a
college educated
american who usually comes from decent
family
upbringing they are the ones that can
speak the corporate english
because then you have the class issues
in america so
we can only accept the ones that can
speak in the corporate english
so the ones who enter the field
typically have a comfortable
family life comfortable life they're
like i had colleagues
near me who all had like chanel watches
and cartier bracelets
upon entering the workforce as a
recruiter making 35k
in new york so so the people who enter
the industry are not financially
motivated a lot of them are not
because they recruit from these pools of
people who are already
in a financially comfortable situation
so what happens is the people who
actually sustain and again like i said
see the commercial opportunity and are
willing to work for it
are few and far between because the
reality is you can also just quit
and get some other job and make like a
decent living and be okay
right so again in the us i think we have
this massive
labor shortage and this is still the
case
we have a massive labor shortage where
there's just not enough people
staying in the business coming into the
business so what happens is
the recruitment companies who know what
they're doing extremely extremely
profitable
it's really interesting to say that
because um
so a bit of context so i so i think i
don't know if you know lewis adams
dunstan at darwin recruitment
um i don't know if you've connected with
him he said that you both have spoken
um in the past but so and he was talking
about this right and i think uk
recruitment companies learn this the
hard way right and
basically sort of a typical uk
recruitment business plan
will normally be if things go to plan
get a couple of their like long-standing
employees
first in the ground in new york first in
the ground in la or whatever so
one they know what the company culture
is they know sort of what their values
are and they can cultivate and grow that
in in america
but and then the sort of constant
challenge that i've uncovered multiple
times in this podcast which lewis was
saying and they learnt the hard way is
then
oh right okay so yeah attracting
recruiters for your
agency recruiters for your own
recruitment business here is even more
difficult
for some of the things that you're
saying and then there's this learning of
oh okay down down so look i'm talking to
about a 35k
base the commission you can earn or you
could potentially work for facebook and
it's 150 grand salary or whatever right
as a corporate recruiter
right so he he was really and you spoke
about it there but i guess
and i'm sure you're thinking about this
every single day
how can you move the needle on that then
because for me
the conversations i have uk recruiter
there's loads of uk recruiters that want
to go to the us
and and we'll see how that plans out
with visa delays and all these things
right but
that's i don't know if you've seen that
you speak to uk recruiters that come
over whatever
but um like how can we move the need how
are you how
can you move the needle on on that then
do you think
well part of what we do is we try to
spread the word right there's only so
much social media can do though
like the reality is we're just like a
drop in the bucket like
we're not famous enough that every
single college kid knows us and is like
oh wow
did you recruit told us about recruiting
as a career right and we have no time to
go to every single college
campus to tell people about recruitment
so i think it
it's helpful that recruitment companies
are trying to do that
and they're they're kind of selling
recruitment as a career
um as best as they can the reality is
is like there's systemic issues in this
country that are gonna
cause this gap a continuous gap in the
labor market
and this is just how it is because
unless you
i was lucky that even though my parents
were immigrants i grew up
in a wealthy town that was predominantly
white
i was lucky because my parents
understood how america works
they were like hey if we want our kids
to have a future here
they need to sound white so we need to
grow up
in a white neighborhood otherwise they
will be
severely disadvantaged if they have an
accent and my parents understood this
because they're well educated in china
and they knew
how class affects economic structures
right so i think here you have this
problem again
where a lot of people coming from rural
america or coming from
a disadvantaged neighborhood
unfortunately how
likely is it that they can now speak to
executives
how likely is that to happen so i think
the systemic problem is
way too serious for any of us to correct
the most we can possibly do is
try to talk to college kids who are
young enough who
actually have hopes and dreams and want
to make
commission right you have to catch them
at an age
where commission is appealing because
realistically
once someone gets to being 25 years or
older commission
doesn't sound exciting because they now
want to live in a decent house
they now want to buy food to eat now
they don't want to cook and they don't
want to cost save
so for them a low base high commission
opportunity is not attractive
we have to really educate hopefully the
high school age
and the college age kids to say hey
maybe before you decide to take some
joe schmoe like 70k paying job have you
thought about
potentially amounting to more than that
you know again
however at the end of the day you can't
convince someone to like money
when they don't so it's a very hard
thing for us to change people
and i have this cynical saying at the
end of the day i can't turn poop into
gold
i just can't like they're either gold or
they're not like
there's not you can't convince somebody
to care about money
you just can't like they either want it
or they don't
there's nothing i can say and i've tried
believe me i've tried
to inspire people to say look how money
changed my life wouldn't it
be great to like have so much at a young
age people don't care
but they just need what they need to
live the lifestyle
they care about not everybody needs to
have a car and a ski
house and a summer home not everybody
feels that way or cares enough so at the
end of the day it's
very hard for us to influence the
general public
people have to hopefully learn about
this career
along their journey to getting wealthy
for me it was just luck
it was just luck that somebody called me
and was like hey do you know what
recruiting and i was like absolutely not
i have no idea what this career is about
because they don't teach about it
in school i was just lucky that
somewhere along the way i bumped into
somebody
so again as a wreck direct that's about
as much as we can do
is spread the word and say hopefully
i'll bump into that guy or gal who
has a dream in their heart hopefully i
can bump into that and we do
here and there we bump into those people
and it's nominal
it's amazing seeing someone who's 23
years old who's never made over 50 000 a
year
kill it in their first year and just
absolutely
love the commercial opportunity it
happens
but we have to put a lot of effort into
putting out a lot of videos
connecting with people asking for
referrals it's a manual process
to convert people it's like a religion
if you want people to sign up you have
to go door to door
um so where are where are the so
where where are the growth where the
growth areas and sectors in the u.s then
so
i think two things i'd love you to share
because obviously america is a huge
place
what what sort of states are you quite
excited by
that you see really growing the
recruiters it's just good context
recruiters listen to this
to to know um where the opportunities
are and then two
yeah what are the growth sectors that
you've seen that have done well during
this period and
again thinking of people who are looking
at taking their career to the us what
what sectors
would you be encouraging them to to
consider if they could
well i think every sector that is
candidate driven
and has decent rates and yields is a
good sector
right so it's not like energy is better
than tech it's not like
finance is better than energy you know
it's not so black and white
um and that's the worst is to like chase
certain like oil and gas
popular five years ago don't do that now
right like but again there's money to be
made there so i don't think it's ever
the market that dictates
the success of a recruiter i think it's
more like your natural
perhaps your natural skills aligning
with the potential
style of that network so for instance
pharmaceutical land
it's a lot of older people who are in
their 40s and 50s
than children so you need to relate with
them
you need to really understand how their
risk factors
affect their decision making when it
comes to career moves so it's more so
understanding those demographics
than the construction market you're
dealing with people who are more blue
collar
who are a little bit more like like grab
a drink after work
and these people conglomerate in the
cities that are experiencing
construction growth right so so you
depending on what sector
you just kind of have to look at the
different market verticals and decide
does that fit my style right again like
had i known if i could do
my recruitment career again i would have
probably picked biostatisticians
because i'm chinese and i speak veteran
i should have done biostatisticians
from day one because i just could i it's
an easy in
right they all speak mandarin and
they're a lot of the
hiring managers are chinese and when
would you meet a chinese headhunter
who speaks both languages it's
impossible so i
i should have done that upon looking
back i did just fine the regulatory
writing because a lot of my clientele
were women
who had children and i would like mentor
their kids i would go on weekends and
hang out with their kids and
we do like that is the kind of stuff i
did to break into my network
i would host like pottery painting
sessions i did what i knew my
my network wanted right like a good
example it's like barbecue and jersey
like i want to do barbecue i want to do
a bowling night i wanna these are things
that my network actually has an interest
in
and might be like a fun social thing for
them versus let's say hey let's
set up a fancy yacht in new york and
have all my
candidates from philly drive over it's
not possible right so
understanding your market knowing where
they are and being accessible to them
and nowadays today with like the borders
you know you can just fly anywhere you
want obviously not with covet
but you can fly in the future right so i
did business in cincinnati i did
business in chicago
like you can do business anywhere so
it's less about the location
it's more about like the fit of the
market and obviously your intrinsic
um intellectual capacity yeah
they're not any they're not any
particular states you're excited by then
because
yeah they're just no not really you i
mean i'm a national recruiter so
anything to me is the same like it
doesn't matter if austin
it like austin's it just doesn't matter
because i recruit the same profile in
every single city
right and then i do the relocation so
i'm a national recruiter i've always
been national
from day one so i'm not in a
regionalized model
some recruiters are in a regionalized
model where they can only sell to a
certain location
um and to me that's kind of limiting
because then it's like boston market for
instance it's very insular market it's
only so big
so like at a certain point you just run
out of candidates so then you have to
import them
oh you might as well just do business
also in jersey where you can like
you know shop to each other right so i
think in america because of this
people also relocate nowadays you know
millennials entering the workforce and
aging there's a lot of people that want
to move and need to move
if you're not really national or you
have the capacity to service that you
might be leaving money on the table
um so i don't know if there's any
particular again it's not the location
or the market who makes the recruiters
it's what you make out of it my only
caveat to that is like
low level paying jobs
hey uh i need an admin assistant for 65
000
you have to really question yourself why
is that a market that you want to enter
like why is that it would be because how
could you scale a team
right so you have to look at average
margins and what you think you need
to attract talent and to build a team so
just quickly so
last couple of things before i i'll ask
you the last few questions i just want
to find out
your opinion on reality of uk recruiters
still coming over to the us
i don't know how much experience you had
in that or just the conversations you've
been having
and then two and just want to hear
around um
the actual reality of of how much the
actual commissions
in america like one of the main things
you always heard is look i can recruit
the exact same tech sales person in the
uk
for 15 uk pound uh 15 grand uk pounds
and then in america
i can actually get the exact same skill
set and get paid 40 50
um k dollars right so firstly reality i
know
these are situational things but i don't
know what the conversation you're having
are there's
still going to be opportunities for uk
agency recruiters come to the u.s do you
think
absolutely i mean there exists right now
i know a lot of uk recruiters who
recruit in the us they already do it
they don't even have to be physically
here
as long as you're willing to work the
odd hours you can do it
like when i travel to europe vacation i
work us
hours i'll stay up till 1am and it's
great i get to party all morning
and then work at night it's kind of a
nice setup
because you know if you don't mind the
hours it's nice to get a whole morning
where you don't have any clients or
candidates bothering you right it's
actually kind of cool
so i do see a lot of uk recruiters
already doing that
um and then when they come here yes the
commissions are higher
and this is again a systemic problem
right we don't have
a lot of social benefits like health
care right we don't have
our housing prices are insane so like
to attract talent that's why the
salaries are so high and i noticed that
with even my old market
right i would talk to a gsk employee and
be like oh my god you're a retro medical
writing and you make a hundred thousand
pounds
here you get double in the u.s dollars
like for being you know
even less experienced right so i think
again this is a reality of kind of how
the economic structure works but again
that could hurt you as much as it could
help you
because it's just completely dependent
on the foreign exchange rates
right right now america sounds great and
feels great i don't know what's going to
happen to the dollar
if the dollar tanks and the uk pound is
now double the u.s dollar
i don't know if you want to upgrade your
entire life to come here you know like
you got to kind of think about like uh
is it really worth the squeeze
right um so i do think the us is a great
market so long as the us dollar is great
but the minute the economic wins shift
recruiters today have to be very
globally minded
right because if the dollar depreciates
to be very low
then why am i even going to do it here i
probably wouldn't i probably recruit for
some other country
like because all i need is a phone and
an ability to talk to people
right so i i think that's like more
philosophical but the reality is is like
yes
in the next 10 years at least there's a
lot of opportunity in america and for
brits thinking about coming here
the question you really need to ask
yourself is do you really want to schlep
it again
like you did in year one in your
recruitment career because when you come
here
you have to work all the time so a lot
of times i think people have this vision
of how easy it's going to be
how amazing it's gonna be but the
reality is is you're gonna come here
with a lot of
pressure on your back to perform you're
gonna be in a new city with relatively
little
social network um and then you're gonna
have to stop it
and you're gonna have to figure out the
entire market dynamics you're gonna have
to learn
a lot of things that probably aren't the
same in the uk
like what makes americans tick what are
their risk factors when it comes to
moving and
leaving and you don't know the things
like you used to know you're gonna have
to learn the economic structure
the comp parameters the client base
so there's there's a lot of work to be
had and that's what i've seen i've seen
i used to think
working at a british firm that all brits
by nature of them being british we're
better at recruiting
the reality is they're not a lot of them
come here and they're just
not great they can't bill they're not
very good
and they can't crack the market they're
struggling
right and it's usually because they tend
to not put in the hours
they tend to not be humble enough to
start from the bottom
truly like roblin again like for
business and trying to like starting off
with crappier clients starting off with
lower rates
starting off with less good candidate
like they just can't adjust
to doing that again right and at the
same time they want to live it up
they want to meet the people everyone's
like enamored with the accent they're
just getting a lot of attention and
they don't want to work all the time but
the reality is when you set up a
business
you have to work a lot right so i think
for an experienced recruiter that's been
comfortable
doing pretty well in the uk coming here
is a rough adjustment because it is
going back to basics
yeah so before before we finish down and
we are we okay for time
yeah just so i've got five five
questions before we
finish so look i i absolutely um
love your energy and passion for your
work right and
obviously i saw um your
ink article right where you you work so
hard you sacrifice you've
put in the work and you've you've then
um built up
to a position where you're financially
free under 30. right
so what i wanted to ask you and you've
spoken about your drive and you've as
you said
as you quite rightly said shamelessly
said how might a vet you are by money
right
so what i wanted to ask you was people
listening to this
i don't think enough people are spoken
to about
what to do with their money financial
acumen
right and um this is definitely
something in the uk where you will
you will have in some firms teenagers
early 20 year olds making six figures
right
and they will end up spending that um on
alcohol
and drugs and these types of things
right but and that's fine that's part of
you that's part of your life and part of
growing but
i don't know i would love to just for
you to share just before we finish
like your i know you went to a very um
great uh school in college
but like what would your sort of advice
be for people to start that
sort of curiosity around what should i
be doing with this money that i'm
working so hard to build right that
can build me um income streams for long
term
success and and the platform for my life
right
yeah i i i have my parents to thank for
this because
i grew up in a very like money driven
household where from a very young age my
dad was like you need to start investing
in the stock market
like you need to start like figuring
this out like he didn't know it he
wasn't very familiar with
it but he was like you do though you
need to read you need to listen to this
so in college my dad gave me a book
called rich dad poor dad
robert kiyosaki very famous financial
education book
right so i i read that on spring break
in cancun
like and i was like this is amazing
right that's when i was
already making money as a bartender i
was selling things on ebay i've studied
very little i was actually
running lots of side hustles to make
money because like my parents didn't pay
for you know
anything really if i wanted to eat out i
would have to earn that money myself and
i didn't want to work in my five because
i'm like they get paid nine dollars an
hour
that's like nothing after taxes right so
i i need to just like flip things on the
internet right so i was like flipping
things on internet my dad's like hey you
should buy stocks
so then i started investing like early
and so i went through 2008
that big drop and then i just held on
because i was like this just decreased
60 percent there's
just like no point in selling at this
point it's so low
that like i should just keep it and in
2011 it went double right so
i think from a very young age i was
lucky that my parents kind of told me
don't do drugs don't get
wild and like asians like i'm allergic
to alcohol i'm not like
loving drinking it all the time you know
it like literally hurts me like i lose
my voice it's not very uncomfortable
so i think again like my dad was a
gambler like he is
like what he's like a classic kind of
immigrant man that came to the country
got into gambling really badly like
almost ruined our lives
ruined our livelihood so i saw from a
very young age the consequences
of your actions when you indulge when
you over
indulge in something like a vice like
drinking alcohol like
the opposite sex whatever it may be it
could like it could rip you up it could
ruin your life
so i think from a very young age i had a
world view that was like i'm not gonna
mess up
like i'm not gonna even try i've never
done coke in my life
ever like i've not even tried i've never
even smoked a joint
because very young age i was like look
at my dad i do not want to end up like
that
i do not i don't think you had the time
[Laughter]
oh trust me we partied we were pretty
high but i just never
engaged because i'm like i just don't
want to open up that door
right like so from a very young age it's
like i need to get rich as soon as
possible
because the consequence is working when
i'm old
and that sucks like i really don't want
to do that so from a very young age i
was like
when i started the recruiting job i
lived in a really cheap area
very far from the office and people
would make fun of me and
people would call me oh you're so cheap
and then being asian i got like the dub
i got the whole stereotypical i'm so
cheap asian person like
people would treat like they really
would looking like that and honestly i
didn't care
because i'm like while you're living in
manhattan spending 1500 on rent
like you can't buy nice things because
you are so tight
on money right so i have nice things
even though i lived in a shh
crappy part of town right because like i
was really low my fixed costs were
really really low
i would eat hot dogs i would eat like
cookies
i would subway sandwiches like i would
cook like i would be really cheap
like i would really eat badly right i
never ate salads those were expensive
right like until i really started
billing i didn't really indulge
because it was about survival right so i
don't i don't know how to like
influence people with that some people
just have a different financial and
family upbringing
that makes them feel a different way
towards money for me it was like if you
wasted it
no one's going to give it to you again
and it was darn hard to get it so i
don't want to squander it
right so from a very young age i was
like if you don't take risks too
you're not gonna make any money and
that's another really interesting
dichotomy you see with recruiters
recruiters are so risk-taking but when
it comes to investing
they're really conservative they they
don't know how to invest they don't know
where to invest
they don't want to invest right so like
here and there i'll be a recruiter that
like has some bitcoin
but like i would expect most recruiters
to have purchased bitcoin because it's
like
a very risky kind of like you may as
well right you're making 200 000 a year
why wouldn't you just take 5 000 and buy
bitcoin back in 2017. like why did you
not think of this
and i think it's because recruiters
naturally are also very paranoid
and um worried like anxiety
right i think recruiters like we're
always looking for like the
deal killer we're always looking to
protect ourselves so i get it like i
understand and then recruiters really
again
interestingly enough like i purchased
real estate
outside of new york i did that very
early i bought real estate in really bad
areas
i never wanted to buy a house that i
live in because i want my tenants to pay
for that it's like a basic
very easy equation for me but i think a
lot of recruiters
either because they didn't read rich job
poor dad
recruiters don't read it's another thing
they don't read they don't take the time
out of their day
to study financial education they party
and they go shopping and they go on
vacation and they socialize
a lot they socialize a lot because i
guess the job is really stressful so
they need socialization
i get but like again you're wasting your
own time like you see your co-workers
every single day at work
you do not need to hang out with them on
weekends like i did it for like social
clout
after i did a certain amount i would
just study tax law on weekends
so i was like i don't have enough hours
in the day to socialize with the
co-workers that i see every day at work
like i do not need to put in the hours
like i'm not getting zero
gain out of that activity right like
it's just a blind leading the blind
like what am i getting from hanging out
with people who are just going to drink
and talk about things i'm not interested
in
right i want to get rich i want to
retire i want to retire at 130.
like that was my goal from the very
beginning because i read i read a book
called
millionaire by 30. and i was like great
i want that right so like
i i read books and reading is something
that i think everyone can benefit from i
need to do more of it
right but also taking action if someone
tells you hey buy this stock
i don't try it just do it like i always
even ask my candidates like what kind of
stocks are you buying
like what should i buy and then i'll
just do it like to me it's just like
save money have enough that you can
invest and just
freaking just gamble just gamble a bit
right this is how i
responsibly gamble is i just take risks
like with real estate too i'm buying
crappy areas right and
this back to the real estate point a lot
of recruiters i talk to they're like i
need to buy a house to live in
why why why you need to do that who told
you to do that
society why listen to society is society
rich is average
american well off no because they're
changed to their home debt
right like most americans make 200 000 a
year but they're chained to a 500 000
mortgage and they're very little
external assets right so
it's just like being a contrarian like
stop following your parents advice
and just think for your own like learn
this stuff
on your own time prioritize it because
you work so damn hard
that's the thing too recruiters work so
damn hard it breaks my heart to see
their money wasted
and all the time i try to help my
colleagues like hey maybe don't do that
it's such a waste of money and they're
like
you're just so cheap blah blah blah like
i get so much crap for trying to help
people be cheap
because i'm like oh my god i can't
believe you're spending that much money
on like a mattress
like believe it or not i've never
purchased a new mattress other than the
ones
in my rental homes that i rent out on
airbnb like i just don't i just buy
use things like if i can save hundreds
of dollars i will
like and i'll still do that today i'll
haggle today
like it doesn't matter just because you
get richer doesn't mean you stop having
like
you money still is money a dollar still
is a dollar
right so i just i don't know i'm just
cheap i really just am
like i just didn't grow up with much and
it's hard for me to just
shell out thousands of dollars for
furniture like i just furnished my new
apartment
for like literally under 500. i got free
tables free things like i just get free
stuff from the internet
like you know just that extra effort to
save hundreds of dollars
it's worth it like you know and some
people are like oh
your hourly rate should be higher and
there shouldn't matter i'm like okay
cool
whatever do what suits you i just don't
feel comfortable spending hundreds of
dollars on
things that are just not even that
important instead i could use that money
put it into bitcoin
so i just normally i have a couple of
questions to ask you but i just want to
ask you this
and we'll leave it here like how
because i think this is important to
talk about because it sort of relates to
again
sort of top billers making the money
they want reaching their goals like how
did you actually
feel when you sort of got to a point
where you're like wow
i actually don't have to work for the
next couple of decades
like how did you actually fail totally
so 2016 i retired in january
after five literally like a week after
my five year anniversary i just like
bounced
um at that point i owned like two houses
i was in process of like selling one
buying a bunch of others
and i was just like yay i did it i
won like i won against you life i'm not
free
i'm out of that race 28 out of it
yay me right at this point i have enough
that i don't ever have to work again if
i just
curate myself correctly and what i
really felt
was scared lost confused
and really lonely because what happens
when you're that young
and you don't have to work anymore it's
like what is the meaning of life
you know i was so driven for so long and
i had so many things to be excited about
and so many like
things to do at that point okay i parked
all my money into real estate
and i had tenant issues and then on the
meantime
i didn't have the the lifestyle i had
before with recruitment
with recruitment you're making over 200
a year and you can get all the anchors
you want
you can at that point i was like living
it right like i was you know doing what
i wanted
i still wasn't buying a hundred thousand
dollar jewelry whatever
i wasn't being too extravagant but yeah
like i could eat out i didn't have to
think about money
but to go from making recruitment money
to going to making money off of your
investments
it's still a big drop in quality of life
and
realistically you know having a million
isn't
enough it just isn't enough to like
carry you to have that 200 000
life that you had before because your
money is
fixed at that point and you're kind of
tied to whatever the financial markets
or whatever investment tools
you decided to put your faith into so i
was a little bit scared i was like
i don't want to lose this at the same
time i feel lonely i know what to
live my life with i don't have the
camaraderie i don't even have a day job
like what am i going to do all day
like i wake up at 11 a.m and just be
like yay me
like this is this is what this looks
like right i wake up 11 being like i'm a
sack of lazy bum like i'm a lazy bum
like i'm living so far below my
capability
by being like this lazy person that just
like like
quit so i i think this fundamentally
comes down to
loving working i truly do enjoy working
like i really do enjoy it it's better
than not working and not working i was
skiing on the slopes by myself
and i was like yay for one second and
the other second i was like and what
right so what i get to ski yay i could
also ski with a regular job and just
like
take a day off work you know so very
quickly the novelty
wears off and then back to your point a
lot of top builders yes you've had money
now
yay right but now you need to think what
am i going to do to benefit the world
what am i going to do to like help other
people hopefully tap into this
tap into a similar structure where
wouldn't it be great if everyone in the
world had financial stability
had a certain amount of financial um you
know
the foundation so that became a driving
mission at that point was like
how can i leverage what i have to
possibly also make
money for myself because i don't want to
stop i'm still too young to like just
stop
right like how can i continue to make
big money make good money
and also help others at that point so
that that is where i am today where i'm
like
able to help other recruiters hopefully
see the light
in this opportunity you know recognize
that maybe
they're burnt out for a variety of
reasons unrelated to the actual role
maybe we can help them also spreading
the word about like how amazing this
career is
if you leverage it correctly also giving
great advice to toddlers
how to manage their money by just giving
them like a basic advice of like hey
maybe go buy the 700 000
house like maybe just don't do that
maybe that's not a smart idea
these are the reasons why right because
they they didn't have access to that
knowledge and their parents are telling
them go and do it go and do it right so
i think again like right now i really am
very happy and fulfilled in my life
i'm probably gonna have to work very
hard for the next
many years to really achieve what i want
to achieve but that's exciting thing
about having something to strive for
right it's like you actually have
something to do every day and you're not
bored that you feel like lazy bum
you actually have something to
contribute to the world and leverage
your skill set
yeah no thank you for uh thank you for
sharing that
dan dan it's uh it's been a pleasure
love your energy thanks
for joining me on the podcast and it's
been a real pleasure
awesome it was nice to be on your
podcast thank you so much for featuring
me and of course if anyone wants to
connect i'm all ears
you can find me on linkedin best place
to drop me a note